I'm so nervous because I feel like none
of these went with black panther
we're here to take this quiz which
Avengers infinity war character are you
it's either gonna be Black Panther or
Thor cuz those are those my boobs I
would want to get Captain America oh I
hate to break it to you but they're here
only be one captain and that's me no no
no no no I want Captain America's
physique Thor's superpower ironmans
money Hulk's real strength yeah I'm
going for all Black Panther so anything
that I think would be like purple I'm
going purple but I'm going fan OHS okay
man as the storyline was incredible I
also like vandals could be daddy so I'm
here for it choose an infinity stone
soul is intense cuz you have to kill a
loved one I thought a lot about who
would I throw down there if I had to get
rid of someone I love you have somebody
that you would kill for that no no I
wouldn't mind yeah of course I would
pick time because we just don't never
have enough time I would like to think
I'm a soulful person who would you kill
oh I would take out my eggs I love them
at one point I'm gonna go to time I feel
like the time one is is my jam and I'm
always running late just 5 10 minutes
you know I do with this dude sometimes
if someone were to ask me what kind of
superpower do you want I would say time
I'm gonna go with time time that's a
good one
I'm gonna do reality the way he was able
to like manipulate reality when he like
chopped everyone into cubes do you
remember that that is a very cool one
that was insane what do you think people
most admire about you would you admire
any of these things about confidence is
it a casual confidence what's the
difference like arrogance basically I
don't know you just confident you're
just caught so yeah thanks but awkward
but in a charming way not awkward enough
sure you are I'm just kidding I'm not
really that nice of a person or genius I
was thinking I was a genius maybe you're
not a next person solving you got to
pick one for me hold your hot body just
do it people can depend on me to get
things done very organized
I will task it out
I'm not gonna pick that one I'm loving
and compassionate I'm gonna have to go
with loving and compassionate I'm told
way too often that I'm too nice of a
person no it's just funny how its worded
she's a Star Wars character I would say
Luke but he kind of acts like a little
[ __ ] she's kind of whiny you know he's
going with Han Solo
I gotta go with Han Solo what more of a
badass is there than Han Solo I'm gonna
go with Rey she's a bit of a rebel I
think you're more of a Finn I think
you're courageous I think you're heroic
bb-8 is your Star Wars character he's my
soulmate I can connect with him right
now
okay I'm not here to judge I'm here just
where this is a judgment-free zone I'm
kind of like a robot robot in a hot body
okay I'm definitely a Han Solo I'm
arrogant I'm cocky at some points but
then like I'm foolish and stupid with my
decisions what you're a genius no I know
and I said I wasn't a genius which
character was the most want to make out
with Black Widow hands down I had the
hugest Scarlett Johansson crush Captain
America the beard yeah not even into
facial hair at all but it worked good
more as my jam look I know she's green
but I just feel like me and her have
some things to talk about
you know what I mean just like some not
only is she like sexy beautiful but she
can kick my ass why does that do it for
me I don't know but it does I guess I'm
just gonna have to be a queen and go
with black panther for the culture sorry
Thor what is your weakness I mean the
first ones I can be a bit too impulsive
I'm just gonna impossibly pick that one
tendency of being unfairly dismissive I
have an awful temper yeah I'm like the
Hulk at work I keep it very very to
myself you need me at home tons of holes
in the wall I'm just kidding I have
trouble letting my guard down allowing
myself to be vulnerable with people oh
that's like that's definitely my
weakness yes yes I can also be impulsive
when it comes to Amazon because there's
prime shipping choose an x-men character
not even a challenge it's been my dude
since day one Wolverine like let's be
real I'm gonna win mystique shapeshifter
Yeah right I would use the ability to
prank a lot of people we just go around
off I would I would just mess up with
that yes as long as you're not hurting
anybody you can have fun with it
mystique it's like one of the coolest
characters ever you can be whoever you
want I want to pick Deadpool because I
just
love that character up until recently I
was always Wolverine but in recent
Deadpool Deadpool I have a very subject
mastic personality I'm also romantic
which Deadpool is what's up girl what
would be the first thing you do if you
had an Infinity Gauntlet look definitely
that one I would have to go with make my
number one crush fall madly in love with
me I did a weird look to the camera cut
that out I think if it exists it exists
for a reason if I have been bestowed
with it I should use it but use it right
all right I'm gonna go with eliminate
poverty and economical st. eliminate
poverty and economic inequality like how
can you not take that it only makes
sense to go with eliminate poverty it's
not something that someone could change
like that you know but if you had the
power to sherwood oh yeah
we both got Captain America I really
wanted Black Panther cuz I really wanted
Panos and I know you got Captain America
the good news is that you're a truly
selfless and heroic person with a heart
of gold
the bad news is that you can be a little
too stubborn and have trouble letting go
over the past
Captain America I'll figure it out you
know I got Doctor Strange we have very
different answers to see I got Doctor
Strange the good news is that you're
incredibly intelligent and possessory
talent and insight the bad news is
you're typically standoffish and kind of
mean standoffish and mean I'm not vibing
on the bad news bit I got dr. strange I
know dr. strange is very gentle very
smart he knows what he's talking about
he knows what he's doing he's got the
time yeah I'm stoned
I mean hey I'll take it if you guys want
to find out which Avengers infinity
character you are go and click on the
link below in the YouTube description
and see if you can match up and be a cap
like me or strings like him what are
other people get on this quiz other
people got Captain America and Doctor
Strange that's it nobody got like Hulk
like widow spider-man yeah interesting